أعتقد أن أكبر ما
يواجهه الإسرائيليون الآن هو
حقيقة أنهم منخرطون بشكل أساسي في
ثماني عمليات مختلفة على طراز SWAT،
لذا فإن ما يحاولون القيام به هو أنهم
يحاولون التأكد من عدم وجود
المزيد من الرهائن المحتجزين على
الأراضي الإسرائيلية من قبل حماس إرهابيي حماس
وهذا أمر
سيستغرق وقتا طويلا في بعض الحالات من
المحتمل أه أن يقوموا
بعملية إما القضاء على أه
المهاجمين أو أه التأكد من أه  أنه
يمكن القبض عليهم، لذا ستكون هذه
هي المهمة الأولى بالنسبة لهم، والشيء التالي الذي
سينتهي بهم الأمر إلى القيام به هو كما تعلم كما أعتقد أنه تم
ذكره سابقًا دعم
منطقة الحدود، إذا قالوا
إنهم سيفعلون ذلك أه و  إذًا، أه،
أنت تعلم أنك ترى بعضًا من هذا
بالفعل ولكن سيكون هناك المزيد من الغارات الجوية،
وأعتقد أن المزيد من الضربات المدفعية ضد
غزة والشيء الآخر الذي
سيتعين عليهم القيام به هو أنه سيتعين عليهم
ملاحقة  قيادة حماس
لأنه من وجهة نظر عسكرية بحتة فقط، من
المحتمل أن يتم إيقاف الحركة الأخيرة من خلال الإجراءات الدبلوماسية
ولكن هذا هو الأساس الذي سيتعين عليهم
القيام به في جوهره
لتنظيف ما يحدث في إسرائيل أه نفسها على
الأراضي الإسرائيلية و  ثم انتقل
إلى غزة نفسها، وبعد ذلك بالطبع
عليهم أن يقلقوا بشأن الرهائن الذين
أخذتهم قوات حماس معهم
إلى غزة، لذا ستكون هذه
سلسلة معقدة للغاية من الأحداث التي
ستنكشف خلال اليوم التالي أه أنا  سأقول بعد
48 إلى 72 ساعة أن هذا هو
سؤالي التالي لأنه بينما يحول جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
تركيزه إلى السيطرة على غزة، وقد
سمعت تلك التحذيرات من رئيس
الوزراء ومن مسؤولي جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي إلى
السكان أو المدنيين هناك في
غزة بالمغادرة  تلك المناطق السكنية
غير متأكدة على الفور من المكان الذي
يمكن أن يذهبوا إليه بالضبط وهذه الكثافة السكانية العالية
أه تعرف مساحة 140 ميلًا مربعًا ويسكنها
2 مليون شخص أه يعيشون هناك ولكن
أيضًا ذكرت حقيقة أنك
تعرف العديد من هؤلاء الرهائن الإسرائيليين
الرهائن أه من المفترض أن بعضهم  تم
نقلهم جنود IDE إلى غزة
ولديك بالطبع حماس أه قادة هناك
يقولون أنك تعلم التحذير من أي
نوع من الهجمات في أه غزة كيف سيتجنب
الجيش الإسرائيلي أه وقوع إصابات غير مقصودة عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالرهائن والمدنيين أه
الناس الذين يعيشون في
غزة نعم إنه  سيكون الأمر صعبًا حقًا،
وليس لدي شعور جيد حقًا
بشأن هذا الأمر لأنني أعتقد أنه
لا يمكن تجنب الحوادث المدنية
لسوء الحظ، فهذه واحدة من تلك
المناطق كما ذكرت، وربما تكون
أكثر الأماكن كثافة سكانية على وجه الأرض من
حيث الكثافة السكانية  وهي
حقًا منطقة لا يمكنك الذهاب
إليها في أي مكان، لذا على الرغم من أن الإسرائيليين
قد أعطوا تحذيرات للناس أه
المنطقة مغلقة بشكل أساسي، كما تعلم أن
بعض الناس يطلقون عليها سجن درهم مفتوح
أه وهذا نوع ما لدينا
لدينا مخيم كبير للاجئين
مخيم كبير للاجئين الفلسطينيين في غزة وهذا مكان
لا يمكن لأحد أن يغادره بشكل أساسي
وهذا وضع صعب وصعب
لا يستطيع الناس الذهاب إلى أي مكان وسيكون جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
أه مجبرًا على التعامل مع
الأشخاص الذين هم  في جوهر الأمر،
الأشخاص المحاصرون هم في الواقع
خطرون جدًا، فهم يقاتلون وهذا ما
سيواجهه الجيش الإسرائيلي،
وسيكون الأمر صعبًا للغاية إذا
لم تنتصر الدبلوماسية في هذه
المرحلة.